측정 결과를 설명하는 행렬이요. 그럼 이걸 조금 더 자세히 살펴볼게요. 일반적인 측정에 대해
추상적으로 생각한다면, 그 측정을 채널 Φ로 표현할 수 있어요. 채널의 입력 시스템은
측정되는 시스템 X이고, 출력 시스템은 시스템 Y인데, Y의 고전적인 상태들이 측정 결과에 해당해요.
어떤 양의 정수 M에 대해 0부터 n-1까지의 정수를 측정 결과로 보는 거죠.
그리고 측정 결과는 고전적이기 때문에, 시스템 X에 대한 모든 입력 밀도 행렬 ρ에 대해
출력 Φ(ρ)가 대각 밀도 행렬이어야 해요. 예를 들어 qubit의 표준 기저 측정에 대해 생각하고,
그 측정이 채널로 표현된다고 생각하면, 화면에 있는 것처럼 표현할 수 있어요.
입력 밀도 행렬이 ρ라면, ⟨0|ρ|0⟩의 확률로 결과 0을 얻게 되고,
⟨1|ρ|1⟩의 확률로 결과 1을 얻게 돼요. 이 고전적인
측정 결과들을 밀도 행렬로 표현하면 해당하는 채널에 대한 이 식을 얻게 되는데,
이게 바로 완전 위상 감쇠 채널이에요. 이는 완전 위상 감쇠
채널이 극단적인 형태의 디코히런스를 나타낸다는 생각과 일치해요. 디코히런스는 여러 의미일 수 있지만, 제가 이 용어를 쓸 때는
양자 상태가 고전적으로 되려는 경향을 말하는 거예요. 우리가 다루는 시스템 주변의 환경이
어떤 의미에서 관찰하고 있기 때문인데, 다시 말해 측정하고 있는 거죠.
그래서 측정 결과는 방금 설명했던 것처럼 채널로 표현될 수 있어요. 하지만 이건 단순한 가능성이 아니라
일반적인 측정의 특성화예요. 제가 말하려는 건 이런 거예요. 물론 측정을 나타내지 않는
채널들도 있어요. 출력이 항상 대각 밀도 행렬이 아닐 수 있거든요. 하지만 어떤 입력 상태 ρ를 선택하든
채널의 출력이 항상 대각 밀도 행렬이라면, 그 채널을 반드시 화면에 표시된 형태로,
즉 합이 항등 행렬이 되는 양의 반정치 행렬들의 모음인 어떤 측정에 대해
표현할 수 있어요. 이게 여러 이유로 좋은데, 그중 하나가 측정을 행렬들의 모음으로 정의하는 방식이
아무것도 빠뜨리지 않는다는 걸 기본적으로 알려준다는 거예요.
다르게 말하면, 측정을 채널로 생각하는 이 방식은 운용적이거나
공리적이에요. 측정이 무엇이어야 하는지, 즉 양자 정보를 고전적인 정보로 변환하는 물리적 과정을 포착한다는 의미에서요.
그리고 이게 순수하게 대수적인 첫 번째 측정 표현과 완전히 동등한 것으로 밝혀졌어요.
이 동등성의 증명은 이 영상에서 다루지 않을 거예요. 하지만
어렵지는 않고, 관심 있다면 영상 설명에 링크된 강의 자료에서 증명을 찾을 수 있어요.
주어진 상태의 시스템에 일반적인 측정이 수행될 때 어떻게 되는지 다뤘는데,
적어도 파괴적 측정의 경우에 대해서는요. 다음으로 부분 측정에 대해 다룰 거예요. 복합 시스템의
일부만 측정된다는 의미예요. 정확히 말하면, 밀도 행렬 ρ로 표현된 상태에 함께 있는 시스템 쌍 XZ가 있다고 하고,
합이 항등 행렬이 되는 양의 반정치 행렬들의 모음으로 표현된 측정이
시스템 X에만 수행된다고 해요. 자연스럽게 이 결과는 측정 결과이고,
파괴적 측정에 대해 이야기하고 있으니 측정 과정이 시스템
X를 파괴한다고 상상할 수 있어요. 하지만 여전히 시스템 Z가 남아 있고, X의 측정이 Z의
상태에 어떤 영향을 미치는지 이해해야 해요. 먼저 결과
확률에 대해 얘기해볼게요. 시스템 X만 측정하고 있으니까, 다양한 결과들이 나타날 확률은
X만의 상태에만 의존할 수 있어요. 즉 X의 축소 상태에만 의존할 수 있다는 거예요.
특히 어떤 주어진 결과 a가 나타날 확률은
이전과 같은 공식으로 주어져요. 즉 PA와 X의 축소 상태 ρ_X의 곱의 트레이스예요.
상태 ρ_X는 ρ에서 Z를 추적(trace out)해서 얻어요. 그래서 이를 대입할 수 있고,
바로 명확하지는 않지만, 얻은 식은 화면에 표시된 것처럼 대안적으로 쓸 수 있어요.
시스템 Z 위의 항등 행렬과 PA의 텐서 곱에
ρ를 곱한 것의 트레이스예요. 이건 확인해볼 가치가 있는 등식이에요. Z에는 아무것도 하지 않으니까
이런 식으로 Z 위의 항등 행렬이 나타나는 게 직관적으로 맞아요. 하지만
대수적으로도 확인할 수 있어요. 먼저 ρ가 두 행렬의 텐서 곱인 경우를 고려하고, 그 다음
선형성을 이용해서 모든 ρ에 대해 성립해야 함을 결론짓는 것을 추천해요. 그리고 PA가
양의 반정치라거나 ρ가 밀도 행렬이라는 사실에 의존하지 않는다는 점도 말해두고 싶어요. 이건
PA와 ρ 자리에 어떤 행렬을 놓더라도 성립하는 등식이에요. 식이 의미가 있는 올바른 차원을 가지기만 한다면요.
이제 Z의 상태가 측정에 의해 어떻게 영향 받는지 살펴볼게요. 자연스러운 접근 방식은
제 관점에서 측정을 채널로 생각하는 거예요. 여기 우리 측정과 연관시키는 채널이 있고,
이걸 시스템 X에서 고전적인 상태들이 측정 결과에 해당하는 새로운 시스템 Y로의 채널로 생각하고 있어요. 그래서 이 공식에서
σ는 시스템 X만의 상태를 나타내요. 쌍 XZ가 상태 ρ에 있는 동안
이 채널을 시스템 X에 적용하면, 여기 있는 밀도 행렬을 얻게 돼요.
다시, 이걸 확인하는 데 필요한 만큼 시간을 가져요. 다시 한번, 먼저 ρ가 두 행렬의 텐서 곱인 경우를 고려하고
그 다음 선형성을 이용하는 것을 추천해요. 이제 첫 번째 시스템이 고전적이고
두 번째 시스템이 양자인 이 유형의 상태를 밀도 행렬
강의에서 예시로 본 적이 있어요. 각 a는 어떤 확률로 발생하는데, 그게 두 번째 텐서 인수의 트레이스예요. 그래서
이 두 번째 텐서 인수들을 확률을 곱한 밀도 행렬로 생각할 수 있어요. 따라서 특정 측정 결과 a를 얻었을 때
Z의 상태를 구하려면, 그냥 확률로 나누면 돼요. 다시 말해
두 번째 텐서 인수를 자기 자신의 트레이스로 나눠서 정규화하면 돼요. 요약하면, 쌍 XZ가 상태 ρ에 있는 동안
X에 대한 측정을 수행하면 이런 일이 일어나요. 첫째로, 각 결과 a는
항등 행렬과 PA의 텐서 곱에 ρ를 곱한 것의 트레이스와 같은 확률로 나타나요. 둘째로, 결과